what's up fam for getting this juicy
episode for UFC 292 few Road dates for
your Covina California it's me and Brian
the kid Mr AKA ranks aka Big Gay Al our
co-headlining for the first time in a
hot second in Covina that's one night
only Covina laugh factor it's a great
little theater out there in Covina one
of my favorite spots in a hot second
that's September 8th that's a Friday two
shows only because Saturday September
9th we had to uh just take away because
we're in Austin for the fight campaign
for Izzy ver Strickland so we'd be we
will be with Mr Joe Rogan on September
9th but September 8th it's going down me
and Brian Callan two shows only that
will sell out get your tickets right now
as you're listening stop listening to me
and go buy those tickets then in
September I'm also in Spokane Washington
with my favorite Club Spokane Comedy
Club September 21st through the 23rd
skank fast Vegas September 29th to
October 1st Niagara Falls New York those
tickets go on sale this Friday that's
November fourth and fifth that's a
Friday and Saturday in New York Niagara
Falls it's a casino out there so
definitely come out otherwise they give
the tickets to just random old people
that gamble into awkward shows so fans
come on out Niagara Falls Casino in New
York
New York Niagara Falls and then we also
be announced in Chicago and Iowa for the
rest of the year so a bunch of dates on
there but I'll see you guys soon Spokane
you're up first all right you weighed
all year all freaking year the time it's
finally arrived football is back college
football is back my CU Buffs are going
to run the table this year it's all
happening this Saturday you got
Traditions the tailgate tailgates and
the great offers from my friends at
DraftKings Sportsbook right now new
customers can score 200 in bonus bets
instantly when they bet just five
dollars on any college football bet you
got USC playing this Saturday you got a
bunch of other big name teams coming up
your favorite team watch your team get
the tailgate and make money with
DraftKings my CU Buffs are coming out
the gate hot baby it's Deion Sanders
kick off the season with draftking
Sportsbook download the app now use code
shop show schab show new customers can
score 200 in bonus bets instantly when
they bet just five dollars on any
college football bet only on draftking
Sportsbook with the code Shop show
gambling problem call 100 Gambler New
York call 8778 Hope and why or text Hope
and why that's 467-369 in West Virginia
visit
www.1800gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please play responsibly in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
Resort Kansas 21 or older in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and
state-specific responsible gambling
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com football terms
it is August 21st Monday morning on this
rainy rainy drive into the studio here
um I think it got downgraded from a
tropical hurricane to just a tropical
storm
but uh it's been raining here man it
it's weird because people I went to the
grocery store to pick up some stuff to
grill uh for the fights dude it was like
uh remind me back in the
when the city was shut down for uh sick
reasons
I have to talk like that so we don't get
banned but um remember people storing up
on like toilet paper and food that's how
it was at the grocery store again I'm
like oh dang dang dang some places were
way worse than others we didn't get it
too bad the it was pouring so much water
I guess it goes under the road when I
pull out of my driveway some of the road
is gone like floated down did you guys
have any problems where you're at
no did you feel the earthquake yes big
time I was at lunch with uh my father
and mother-in-law and my whole fam and
it was like like it was it lasted a
while too and there's a kid like
probably 17 just like then the phones
were going and he's like looked at me I
was like what but I gotta save these
kids first man it ain't happening this
thing goes under my son was like Dad
went under the table I'm like tight move
dude you know what's going on [__]
you know like come on dude enjoy your
lunch man
but uh yeah coming fresh off this
hurricane hopefully everybody's okay out
there
uh you had a big big UFC Fight Night UFC
2 92 in Boston Boston uh went down and
uh it delivered in some ways and in some
ways it did not the prelims were popping
bro the prelims were popping daddy
uh I mean even all the way from Andre
petrovski Gerald Mercer was a good fight
those two boys are jacked
um and then it led right into the
prelims on ESPN ESPN plus with Brad
Katona and Cody Gibson for The Ultimate
Fighter strap that was a great fight
people need to relax saying it's Forrest
Griffin and uh our boy um
who's at Forest and uh Stephen Bonner
come on relax relax it was good it was a
really fun fight I thought Katona was
screwed in that first round but he came
back and got it together Cody Gibson
little Steph
I just again I I I'm not hating on
anybody
with with Kurt hollabaugh and Austin
Hubbard his you know he's a black belt
his transition was filthy from the arm
bar right into the the triangle there
filthy transitional filthy
I'm just especially when I was watching
really with Cody Gibson with his knees
he has the bad knees how stiff he is you
and Brad Katona with Kurt hollabaugh
what do we do with him that was my whole
thing with this Ultimate Fighter what do
we do
what do we do you don't have bad and
weight with Brad
he's gonna be a top 10 guy with Kurt let
me top that I I just I don't know the
the reason her Madness behind that
season and then you're not getting Conor
McGregor or Chandler which we'll get
into you're not getting that this year
hopefully early next year I don't know
but you're not getting that anytime soon
so it's like what was the season four
it's just a weird thing weird thing uh
Brad Tavares Chris Weidman tough one to
watch you boys watch that in here I text
you guys during I think yeah during the
prelims I said God sucks we're not doing
a companion we should have I just
couldn't get on the ball there but I
also haven't had a night off from a big
pay-per-view in a hot second so it was
nice to watch it but I do miss doing the
companion especially when we have the
right crew together
um but Brad Tavares and Chris Weidman uh
you know Chris is 39 no one really comes
back better after a leg injury like that
you know you had
spider came back of course but it was
never the same I don't think Connor's
gonna be the same it's just dim the
rules it's just you snap your leg and
two like that you just never come back
at full strength
um you know Chris Weidman also has
father time working against him at 39. I
don't like that first comeback fight
which is a phenomenal story and shout
out to Chris White and Freeman jumping
into the octagon
but UFC matchmakers Brad Tavares that
that's his welcome party back brat
Tavares this Savage vet who's fought
everybody in the freaking middleweight
division let him get his whistle wet man
let me get his beak wet before he toss
him in there with these Savages now
granted Brad's fallen on some tough
times but he's only lost to really the
best of the best Izzy shabazzian
especially at the time Shabazz in
um uh Enriquez duplici's and he lost the
Bruno Silva and beat Chris Weidman but
he he has some big wins there beating
Neymar card Lorenz Larkin
he's also the top top guys you know he's
lost to the very top Joel Romero uh
Robert Whittaker obviously Izzy but he's
such a tough night in the office for
anybody ridiculous takedown defense
great leg kicks great striking handsome
bastard handsome is all get out right
Jesus Christ am I right I guess it's hot
and his leg kicks were it's just I think
there's there's such a respect there too
with Brad Tavares early on he's he's
kind of like all right and there's the
nut shots which I think should be an
automatic point deduction right away
those are bad dude those are so bad now
it's a Orthodox and Southpaw issue it
doesn't matter they should always take a
point I think but that's never going to
happen they literally just kicked each
other enough like four times each
whatever but um Brad was kind of showed
too much respect and then once that wore
off he's like I'm gonna destroy your
legs I'm gonna just gonna take out your
goddamn legs oh you only have one good
wheel not anymore and just royally
screwed them you know just dismantle
them it's tough to watch man it's really
really tough to watch 30 27 that's fair
um
I would hope Chris weidman's done or I
know Chris came back and was after the
fight was like you know this isn't the
end of my story I want another one
they they owe it to guys like Chris
Wyman let him go out on a shield as far
as give them a favorable matchup for
where he's at Tavares is not the guy
tavar is still a dog man give him a guy
who one foot in one foot let him get a
win you owe it to him I'm gonna win and
then even widen was like I think it's
offensive they put me on the prelims I
agree with what he's done former champ
on the prelims so
that was a bummer to watch but also
and we'll get to Connor too I'm sure in
current events Connor was tweeting about
how inspirational it is that Chris Wyman
I think this actually hurt Conor's
chances coming back too because I think
them seeing why I'm like oh this is this
is not good this is a liability and the
cameraman zooming into Chris's leg like
right before the fight showing like the
stitches you're like what the [__] is
this man we're already thinking about it
get it you know get out of here but I
think Chris Wyman it's not they had a
such a poor performance just that you
can see he's just hindered it's just
it's a super liability I think UFC's
thing you have Connor and Connor's this
in bratavares is a monster has fought
everybody toe-to-toe monster
but Conor's on a different level Conor
ain't coming back fighting some
you know just regular Contender or some
guy are the top 15. Connor's time out
fighting the top tip of the spare guys
so UFC saying that going oh no we need
to pull pump the brakes on this a little
bit that's what we need to do we we
can't have this so I I think you
actually hurt Conor's chance to come
back too I think UFC was like oh my God
yeah hold up hold up this ain't good so
I think it actually hurt Connor
um and then kick off the main card you
got Marlon Cheeto Vera our boy thick boy
alumni versus Pedro Munoz Cheeto got it
done let's take a little break from
talking all this real housewives of
Ultimate Fighting Championship because
I'm happy to announce we just partnered
with my friends at sheath underwear Bros
this underwear game out there is tough
on the streets you're wearing the Tidy
whities you got streaks in there your
girl you're telling to buy darker colors
so you can't see the peepee stains in
the front and the streaks in the back
well thank God for sheath underwear it
makes the most comfortable briefs I've
ever worn and I only wear briefs I don't
mess around with the boxers I'm not a
frat bro I'm a dad I wear briefs dude
every time you hear my voice or if
you're able to see my face it would be
obvious that I'm wearing a pair of
sheath box or briefs they're stretchy
fabric isn't may have the moisture
wicking technology that makes them super
soft all right chugging your junk like a
warm hug keeps everything cool
comfortable and right in place all right
sheath is particularly useful for
staying cool if you're working out in
the summer days right now but also keeps
you warm comfortable and dry and cold
environments as well after trying Chief
you can never go back to those old tired
Brands all right that your grandpa used
to wear particularly I love the Dual
pouches that keep your man part separate
it's a game changer they shouldn't be
tangling up down below they shouldn't be
grappling with your wiener we don't want
that sheath uses materials like bamboo
and mesh for even more cooling Comfort
we are sure they'll be the most
comfortable underwear you ever put on
your junk sheath also has bamboo shirts
hoodies all designed for maximum Comfort
that's what we do as comfort baby at
sheath go to sheathunderwear.com that's
s-h-e-a-t-h-underwear.com all right use
the promo code shop schab you get 20 off
the best underwear on the plant that's
sheathunderwear.com today use promo code
shop schab you get 20 off the best
underwear of all time get rid of your
dad's undies get into sheath this
episode of the shop show for UFC 292 is
brought to you by Shopify you could
trade a benchwarmer for a goat you do it
right get your business a game changing
pick up by choosing the Commerce
platform with the internet's best
converting checkout that's Shopify
Shopify is the Commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of business
worldwide whether you're a garage
entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify is the
only tool you need to start run and grow
your business without the struggle
Shopify puts you in control of every
sales channel so whether you're selling
satin sheets from shopify's in-person
POS system or offering organic olive oil
on shopify's all-in-one e-commerce
platform we got you covered Sports say
less selling signed sneakers all right
we're offering official outfielders
merch or UFC fighter shorts whatever it
is you got it Shopify and once you've
reached your audience Shopify has the
internet's best converting checkout to
help you turn them from browsers to
buyers Shopify Powers 10 of all
e-commerce in the US and Shopify it's
true only Global Force powering all
birds rothies Brooklyn and millions of
other entrepreneurs of every size across
over 170 countries all right this is a
possibility powered by Shopify sign up
for one dollar per month trial period at
shopify.com
schab that's lowercase shop schab that's
shopify.com go to shopify.com shop take
your business to the next level today
today
I think uh Rogan and DC were a little
off on the commentating there when they
they kept praising Pedro he had high
output and they're like you know Cheetos
slow starters tend to hurt them
and they kept alluding to that but when
you Pedro let's say would land three
really it was like two to one because
Marlon actually out uh paid some second
third round
um or a match at least it wasn't that
big of a difference but Pedro would
throw two to three shots not many was
Landing Cheeto would land one jab and
bust up his face so again I side within
this after Tom Cruise who sat in with
the judge's criteria where damage is
most important you watch that like yeah
cheetahs win this fight I didn't think I
thought you know 30 27 so 29 28 I can
see how you give Pedro the first round
but definitely 20 29-20 across the board
30 27 I'm cool with that but I thought
Cheeto easily won that fight I mean
Pedro had a lot of output which is good
but it's all about damage significant
strikes landed cheetah won that battle
does it kind of an easy night in the in
the office for Cheeto that's not you
know Paige was a monster he's following
hard times and he's won what two out of
his last eight if I'm if I'm mistaken
one one uh let me see one two three four
wait one two three four five
so he's lost five out of his last what
is that one two three four five six
seven eight he's lost five his last
eight one being a no contest the sugar
Sean I still would have liked sugar
Shawn to get that win
um but
but again with Pedro who look who he's
lost to Al Joe Frankie Jose Aldo
um
Al Jermaine Sterling Dominic Cruz then
Cheeto so you know he's he's that guy
like to me when people say gatekeeper I
don't think it is a I don't like it as a
negative thing to me a guy like Paige
would be a gatekeeper in order for you
to crack into the top ten in order to
crack in the top five it's not a bad
thing it just means you're so good
you're so goddamn good but you're not
top five good your gatekeeper to get to
the title to get to the title run
not a gatekeeper mean if you deserve to
be in the UFC that's it there's I think
there's different tears to being a
gatekeeper for Pedro to be a gatekeeper
if he can be Pedro yeah you're going
you're damn good your top five top six
top seven top eight Talent he's that guy
you know you want to crack in the top
eight here's Pedro good luck and he's a
handful he's good at everything there's
guys like that when people say geeky but
I think it can be negative and they're
like well no in order to be gatekeeper
means they're gatekeeper you being in
the UFC no no Pedro's fought the who's
who he has some huge huge wins
um you know Jimmy Rivera Cody garbrandt
Brian Caraway Rob font like he's beat
some damn good guys but I I do think
he's getting Split Decision with John
Dodson the magician for God's sakes
who's started everybody in bare knuckle
now but a gatekeeper mean you beat him
in the top ten he's a gatekeeper you get
into the elite elite guys he's just just
a notch below the tip of the spare guys
that's what that means
but for for Cheeto I I thought he he
looked really good in that fight first
he always give me a slow starter it's
just what he is you know so three rounds
can kind of get dicey for him
you know the after suga's fight you know
he called out Cheeto I think it was
smart
um I mean I don't want to skip over the
other but in regards to Cheeto so
cheeto's my boy I hope Cheeto gets the
fight it does make sense I can so I can
argue whoever wants to debate this why
uh
marab should get the shot why Corey
Santa Hagin should get the shot and why
Cheeto can't it's up to the UFC all
three of them have a valid point why
they should fight sugar for the title
you make a case for any of them as far
as who on paper if it's black and white
take all the politics and all the hype
out of it who deserves it morab
what one nine in a row there's a there's
an argument you know he's from the same
camp as Al Joe there's a lot of that
um do I want to see that fight not next
if I'm UFC that's not next you're not
doing that one next
you're just not does he deserve it why
because he's beat everybody including
Brad Katona uh John Dodson Cody stamen
Marlon Marais Jose Aldo and Peter Yan
and like beat the brakes off everybody
yeah he deserves it he really does but
it it's just not you can build The
Narrative of the revenge and the
Redemption the overall aljo there's that
and we can get to that
but I I don't think the UFC is going to
do that and people say you know Sugar's
gotten Dana White Privilege or UFC
privilege
this happens in every sport it's not a
sugar thing you know or a Patty thing
but
it's not a it shouldn't be called it
shouldn't be called Dana White Privilege
it should just be called the star
privilege that it happens in all sports
so with Suga it's not that he had an
easy run in the UFC especially it's very
black and white when it comes to mixed
martial arts The Dana can only control
so much you have to perform and they
they can't
they can't make you win fights you know
especially if you're starching people
like uh he's done you know with the with
the Peter yon fight that's a tough fight
for Sugar Sugar doesn't win that we're
not even taught having this conversation
so they can only
quote unquote as they say online protect
him so much until he has to you know do
the work but the where the favoritism
comes in and rightfully so remember if
you're a business just think about it
would you rather have marab as your
champion
entertaining guy no doubt entertaining
guy wrestler pure wrestler striking's
you know whatever but as far as
wrestling goes tenacity endurance for
days
not not the biggest crossover as far as
pop culture and the twitch and the
stream and like uh like a like a sugar
so think about would you rather have
maram
aljo
or Suga if you have to pick the three in
your business owner take your bias out
of it take if you're from you know
Arizona if you're from where murab's
from if you're from Al Joe in New York
take that away from it just as a
business you're looking at those three
who would you want as your Champion it's
Suga he checks all boxes he he's [__]
great in front of a cameras remember the
Camry doesn't like he has the young
audience he crosses over into pop
culture he's massive on social media
he's a striker
so you know you can get an entertaining
fight and what you want is entertainment
you want to put butts in the seats
that's what sugar does so you're going
to control as much as you can to make
sure that guy is the face of the UFC
they can only do so much and they've
done it with a number of guys but think
about it anyone who wants to hate on
that it's a business at the end of the
day it's what sells tickets so really
the most clear one we've ever seen is
Alex Pierre Alex pierra granted has all
the skills in the world my God is that
guy skilled as far as striking goes so
what is UFC going to do could they have
made his route to the title tough [__]
yeah they could have made it a nightmare
for that guy an absolute nightmare in
the middleweight division a nightmare
but
with his skill set and his story with
Izzy they're gonna Fast Track him
because it's good for the UFC
it makes sense for the UC it makes sense
for the fans there's a narrative there
it's going to put butts and seats that's
why they're doing that so they literally
catapult him straight to the top for
good reason you would do the same thing
too if you ran the UFC
and now now the guy comes over to like
again they can only protect him so much
so you want to go light heavyweight all
right dude we're not just gonna give you
you know a rat kick or crylov or Johnny
Walker or Anthony Smith or ozdamir or a
Cleo Roundtree where you just or even a
Yuri for that matter where it's just a
perfect striking matchup where you have
the advantage
we're gonna give you young guy can
grapple he's big former champ it's gonna
be tough you get past him we can work
with you but here you go man you got to
earn this you earned it so again it can
only do so much but if you do pass those
tests we're going Sizzler daddy we're
going Sizzler so back to to Cheeto marab
aljo that whole division
if I'm the UFC morob's not next
he's not we can paint the picture there
does it do good numbers yeah it does
good numbers does it do the same numbers
as Cheeto no to do the same numbers as
even a Corey sandhagen no
just do them numbers as a rematch with
aljo no so
you can see which way the UFC is going
to lean and it's brilliant by Suga
that's what makes him a star the guy's
aware of his surroundings he's aware of
kind of predicting things that make
things come to fruition for him to get
on and goes uh which where's Cheeto at
did he win tonight because yeah let me
guess boring and and to be fair too
if if sugar is your chance which he is
he does have that blemish of Cheeto on
his record you can call it what do you
want I know you know sugar is like I
never lost a fight and he holds up the
zeros all good Cheeto did beat him in
straight up with the leg kicks that
compromised him like you go back and
watch that fight Cheeto beat him so if
I'm if I'm sugar I want that a it's a
best matchup for you marab again just
stylistically is a tougher matchup than
all those guys so it's a more exciting
matchup because cheeto's gonna a play
that game of striking with him he's a
slow starter and he is the one loss on
your record
makes a lot of sense so it's brilliant
by Suga and also this is where the
favoritism comes in because UFC's you
know that makes a lot of sense when you
plant those seeds you'll see that makes
more sense
because the murab
that's gonna happen but let's not do it
yet we'll get to that if I'm the FC I'm
the exact same way
it's like uh Maga Madoff at light
heavyweight not yet we have so much more
to do over here we can sell way more
tickets by pairing these guys up first
it's just what it is
you can call it the Dana White Privilege
no no it's the business privilege you're
good for marketing you're good for
tickets you're good for eyeballs you're
good for pay-per-view that's what it is
so the The Dana White Privilege isn't
really a thing it's more of the business
privilege because you're good for
business that's sugar is great for
business
go back to the the card chain for me
so there's a case for all those guys but
I do think Cheeto would be next
take out my bias take out all my bias
and Sugar's Sean not calling out Cheeto
and I love Cheeto I want to get the
title shot there's argument Corey San
Diego have more of a of a shot at the
title than Cheeto because don't forget
sanhagen just beat him
so there's people are gonna be upset no
matter what you have to cheat on like
wait hold up what about marab what about
Corey saying he just beat him dim the
rules sugar wants this guy and also
where sugar is different than Al Joe his
sugar was already had more power than
algae even though aljo is a champ Suga
still had more power
and more Fame more fans he just has that
younger demo he's better for business he
brings more eyeballs he brings in more
endorsement deals so for sugar to go I
want to fight this guy the UFC is going
to listen
this should be said too
I picked alja to win this fight I I
straight up I picked out Joe in this
fight so what I go chin I picked uh aljo
over one I picked waylay I predict she
was gonna absolutely dominate I didn't
think she was gonna whip her ass this
bad this was like World Star Hip-Hop
beat down like Jesus Christ across no
skills but she was just tough it's never
good when they go man she tough that's
never a good sign they should have
stopped that fight probably
um so I picked uh the ones I got right
were wayley Ian Machado Gary
um Cheeto
I picked Chris Weidman but we knew why
picker Swagman right
um
and then I picked Andre petrovski so I
went one two three four four five
ah four for six because let's don't get
to us I did pick Chris White and beat
Brad Tavares that's just because I if
you bet against Chris why I'm in that
fight you're a communist
um but we'll go four for six not
terrible
um with the sugar Shawn aljo fight
these things are always tough to you
know there's a reason why basically aljo
is a three to one favorite stylistically
we haven't seen sugar against a lot of
grapples especially against a guy like
aljo
um and aljo
argue the best bandwid of all time the
thing you don't take into consideration
when you do this stuff is it's sugar
Shawn's time it just is it's sugar
shines time and when you're you're bet
you're bet on the guy to catch the
grappler coming in which he did
brilliantly very via Jose O'Connor a
little different because it was it
wasn't a One-Shot knockoff home run he
had to finish him on the ground
argument early stoppage
I guess
if you know if you're a sugar hater that
you can argue that but it would have
just got worse they yeah they could let
go on another two three seconds we just
kept punch them in the face aljo
twirling up not responding back I'm not
mad at it
could argue you're always a guy what
were you thought it was early I thought
it was early yeah again I'm not arguing
it's not early I think it's early I
don't think it matters that's my
argument is I agree with you 100 early
didn't matter though I think you just
got beat up worse all right you can stop
it you never know them I agree you never
know look at look at uh Shane Carwin uh
and Brock Lesnar yeah they could sure as
hell could have stopped that thing
that's one of the worst beatings I've
ever seen
Brock came back and won I think also
in championship fights here on the
caution of letting it go live yeah
there's so much on the line Doug all
that lifetime of work to get there your
entire life just become world champion
always Edge on the side of letting it go
a little longer and people going ah you
could have stopped that stopping early
but again my argument here early agree
doesn't matter
but you never know
who knows what he would have done there
yeah now we don't know
um go back to the car for me too
so I I do think
um again where I was going with this
you know I picked Al Joe for for a few
reasons but this is what I should have
took more into consideration I know I
owe Brian count two grand but he owes me
like 12 Grand he lost his ass on that
Izzy fight but anyway
again you guys are gonna call it Dana
White Privilege I don't call it that I
call it good business
just think about this and I'm not this
isn't a knock on sugar this isn't making
issues for aljo
aljo fought six months ago against Henry
sehudo
said he didn't want to fight this soon
he fought six months later
now you heard Rogue and allude to go
he's great at cutting weight he is very
good at Ken wait he's a big ass Banning
weight those weight cuts are a beast for
him
so remember he he wanted more time
because he said I'm not 100 UFC foursome
take this fight in six months he just
fought so he just fought
come coming off an injury right you see
he's like my shoulder's not great my
next not great they force him to take
the fight in six months
sugar had a year off
knew he was going to fight aljo had a
year to work on his takedown defense and
prepare for aljo
you know the again it's not Dana White
Privilege it's the UFC going this guy's
a big this guy's the next thing this
guy's the next thing what can we do for
him that's what they're doing there so
for the the odds were not stacked
towards Al Joe to thrive if that makes
sense
remember he did not want to fight this
soon the weight cut is a [__]
for me even though he's a professional
he gets it done
injuries sit short notice for him one
more time sugars had a year preparing
for aljo knew exactly who he's gonna
fight knew exactly what style to prepare
for
so there's there's again that's not Dana
White Privilege that's just business
that makes sense I'm not making excuses
here what sugar Shawn did was insane
insane dude it's just his time it's his
time I tweeted this out biggest star in
the UFC
I think he stepped in he's the UFC's
biggest star it's either him or Izzy
is it you know Izzy definitely has more
credentials cleared out the division so
sugar has more work to do but Sugar's
always has been a guy for a hot second
where his Fame
was was higher than his ranking if that
makes sense until he beat Peter Young
his he Patty pamlett's similar where his
Fame his notoriety is so much higher
than his ranking now Patty don't have
the same skill set as sugar
Sugar's always had that special sauce so
but even then his his Fame has been a
little higher than his ranking he beats
biryan then it gets even now he takes
out aljo his Fame goes way up but we
know his skills we did we weren't aware
of how [__] good sugar was
and I think part of the problem too for
me
we always knew sugar was good we knew he
was his talent so I'm gonna come off the
in white Contender series
but he doesn't have a background like
Alex Pierre like a Jose Aldo like some
of these guys where you look like an Al
Joe with his wrestling credentials
there's no there's nothing I can really
hook hook on to and go he's world class
at this
but this is the new age sugar Shawn's
world class at MMA
he doesn't have to have the the you know
the 80cc Jiu Jitsu wins he doesn't have
to have the the glory world-class
kickboxing credentials he's just good at
MMA so for me the I guess old school guy
I usually latch on that stuff a bow
nickel pedigree and wrestling you know
um you know Izzy had a professional
background
um you look at these guys Pierre had a
professional background you know Jon
Jones with his wrestling background
there's always something from I can hook
into without with Suga I didn't have
anything we we saw him grow up before
our eyes completely different person we
saw him on daylight contendency he's
done now you knew he's special but we
just didn't know he was world class
because it's tough to filter through all
the the [__] on him because there's so
much hype do you know what contendencies
there's twitch there's these Hangouts
takashi69 he's with the milk boys so you
got to filter through all this and when
you get through all the [__] you
realize oh we got special one here and
he he did it he cemented that on
Saturday night my god did he cement that
my God insane is it's very very
connorish a very connorish moment
against Aldo not the same because
remember Auto was like undefeated for
like 10 years world-class Striker but
Alto best bandwidth of all time arguably
you know people always put Dom in there
it's either Dom or aljo there's argument
for both gentlemen but aljo's the man
right now Al just more of a Grappler you
know so what he did to him and it was
just something special man it was
something special
you know
who do you think's a bigger star
Izzy or Suga I mean right now obviously
sugar says it's so brand new but
she could still think sugar is massive
yeah he was big before like the day
white could demonstrates they have Snoop
Dogg blowing them up yeah and then he
does all this stuff and then it just it
seems like every move he makes works out
from like even the Cheeto loss the Pedro
Munoz no contest nothing really gets us
like gets the guy down I I think and
we're gonna get the Ian Machado Gary
here which I have a lot to speak about
what makes guys super special what makes
Conor the biggest star of all time
what makes Izzy Izzy what makes Jon
Jones John ish he might be a bad example
but which shook it's not an act Sugar's
been in here we've been around sugar
it's such a good dude but it's authentic
like when he's talking that [__] it
doesn't feel forced it's not weird it
it's almost like this he's he's pictured
this before he knows what's gonna happen
with Connor when he you know we're not
here to take part we're here to take
over and he would the Mystic Mac and
call his shots and all there's something
special about it doesn't seem forced
when he talks [__] it's not it's not
mean do you know what I'm saying it's
not in the in these young kids
especially in Sugar Shawn's Lane you see
what you know Dylan dance is doing and
Jake Paul and Logan it they're Savages
dude the Ian Gary sat I mean there is no
line that they don't cross it's just a
different world I don't come from I
don't co-signing this stuff shook it
doesn't play that game he did call
Cheeto ugly which is probably the only
mean things done all right he's like I
don't like the way he dresses you know
but what he says you like you're like oh
man you know yeah I think he really
believes that though and you have to to
be as level there's this this thing
where it's authentic and we can we can
feel it we can smell it you just you
just when you see it you know it's hard
to to put your finger on but when you
see it you know it sugar we see it we
know it
when Patty says I'm gonna be the world
champion I don't know if I'm buying that
yet I'm just not I'm not ready to buy it
yet I haven't seen it I haven't seen it
inside that gun well sugar I've seen it
we've seen it you know
which leads me to even Machado Gary the
guy's getting a lot of negativity online
which I don't think he expected I think
it's a number of things
um
the guy is so talented the guy is so
goddamn good so talented walks the walk
in every facet did a did a a like open
workout at a pub in Boston the night
before the fight you know this like at
night at night it was like Hey everybody
and the full set in the full kit hey
everybody this is what we're gonna do
I'll do pictures after we're gonna
you're like dude the night before the
fight Savage checks every box
but I think the battle that he's
fighting is he's Irish Conor's Irish
Connors his hero
um
it it seems to be a page out of Connor's
book
and people that know Ian Machado Gary
say this is him and he's been like this
since he was a kid it's just what he is
but for some reason it just and maybe it
is him but it just doesn't feel
connor-ish but it's it's he's from the
same area he he has he's a striker he he
has that Conor aura about him but it's
just something's off with it something's
off with it and when he does it it's
it's straight up mean
but you got to be a Savage in there
which I I Coast I get it man be a killer
but just comes off as just kind of mean
which I don't like and I don't think
people like and then also remember
Connor born raised in Ireland trained
out of Ireland SBG stayed in Ireland in
the height of his Fame Machado left
a child doesn't train there anymore so I
think there's that
and then I also think
that there's the
the Irish fan base and Americans
feel like they can't like I think
because he reminds us of Conor because
there's so many similarities and
Connor's hurt us so much people are like
nope there's something about where
people like
we don't need this again
I think I think there's I I can't put my
finger up but there's there's there's a
few things where I think the fan base
isn't ready to fall in love with in
Machado Gary like they did Connor
because we we kind of broke our hearts
so many times my heart Casey's heart it
breaks my heart he's my faith bro he's
not failure dude I love Connor you can
do no wrong in my book but when you look
back on you like holy this guy is an
[__] Johnny just a horrible horrible
representation these days we change the
game forever yes he does not get to
where it's at today without Conor
McGregor that's never happened before so
he holds a special place in our hearts
but he's broken our hearts so many times
that we're just we're not ready for in
Gary
I just don't think people are willing to
open their hearts yet we're too hurt
we're like the guy that got his heart
broken by a Scorpio and now another
score becomes like nope I don't do well
with Scorpios you know it's it's that's
all it is but he's the guy he's your guy
he's gonna be around for a very long
time the kid is so goddamn good he's so
good
and we're chatting you know because
we're gonna do the campaign so I was
chatting with the thick boy group chat
there
and for Ian Machado Gary
for what I expect I I think I do think
he's the next thing I'm telling you this
kid is that goddamn good he has all the
talent he's the next big thing
he's the next guy he is it I'm telling
you put that money in the bank he's your
next guy if he's a stock put your money
on Ian Machado Gary he's the guy he's
the [__] dude
that being said
what I think where he's going to get in
his career
I need a big finish over Neil magni
that's my only knock on him and in this
showcase fight the sugar Shawn card Al
Joe there's two main event two basic
Main Events two title fights above you
you're leading into that we got to get a
finish
taking a little break here kids we gotta
keep the house lights on and pay the
boys in the studio this episode of the
shop show is brought to you by the one
the only happy hippo it's one of the
only products I use for every single
thing I do working out being a dad going
to stand up going to podcasts and
whoever it is your boys on that happy
hippo they have Kratom dips the first
ever to market right you're listening
right now you're like how's he breaking
down in uh Machado Gary like this how
did he think of you Machado Gabriel I've
got this is insane I listen I can't take
all the credit it's powered by happy
hippo that's right whoever you want to
get your happy hippo they got powders
they got freaking gummies they have
their instant shots I drink the sour
apple right before I go on air they got
the K dips they got it all it's the only
place you can trust in this wide wide
wild world that they live in happy hippo
if somebody can trust man it gets my
brain turbo charged go to happyhippo.com
promo code is thick23 you get the best
Kratom on the planet all you to do is go
to happyhippo.com promo code is thick
with three C's 23 you get 20 off the
entire site for live share it with your
friend your family member your sister
your therapist your UPS driver your Uber
driver that's Happy hippo.com promo code
is thick 23 for 20 off the entire site
gummies
shots the K dips we got it all the
powders we got it all happy hippo.com
promo code thick23 now let's get back to
the program
now he might say well no and he did say
this he goes no no it showed it showed
Poise it showed experience I didn't go
in there and get all wild and try to get
them out there I was just dismantling I
mean though the 30 24s I agree if there
could be 30 12 I'm with those that was a
massacre I need a finish I need a
highlight finish I I need I need
something that that just builds the hype
because three rounds are just
dismantling Neil Magnum who took it on
two week notice that's not where I want
where I think he's gonna get that
doesn't do it
you look at all the other guys you look
at all the other guys who got to where I
think Ian Machado Gary's gonna get they
destroy guys not just with leg kicks and
let them hang around they find a way to
get it done I do think uh Ian Gary felt
that pressure that's why at the end that
fights 30 more seconds he gets a
submission win cool that's what I needed
so he knew and he was like oh just
punishing him I was trying to you know
show him the difference and that's a fun
narrative but I know he was trying to
get him out of there he kudos to Neil
magnet that's how [__] tough Neil
Magnus
Neil's a very tough fight for anybody
and he made him look amateur man that
fight wasn't
close
so even Gary stock doesn't go down
again just where I ex where I know he's
going I need to finish there
I could be you know like a tough one to
please you know you're nitpicking here
he absolutely destroyed Neil magni who's
ranked 11 who's ranked above him who's
fought everybody in the division who's
beat good guys but for Ian Gary to go
where I know he wants to go and where
he's going we got to get a highlight
finish
can't just be destroying leg kicks and
it goes three rounds that's not going to
get you where you want to go
because how many fights you have in UFC
click on them chin
I'll tell you what I think it's nice for
him too
so his cat's undefeated
um his first fight in UFC he's had two
this third decision
um first fight KO
uh so he's one two three four five six
now click on Connor for me
Conor McGregor yep
um
I'm just showing the comparison here
where where where he's going to go
so uh
so
yeah
here you go so Connor's first six fights
so very similar to Gary his first fight
he had a KO right but he Connor did in a
minute they had decision over Max
Holloway which looking back on was
insane and then after that he goes ko ko
over Dustin Poirier K Over Dennis Siever
that was in Boston in the second round
performance of the night then he had the
KO of Chad Mendes then he had the
legendary kill over Jose Aldo so where
go go back Downton where Ian Machado
Gary is in his career and where Connor
was at
um
one two three four five six
it's just a different time now the
division is way more deeper so you can't
compare it but on his sixth fight in UFC
he fought Chad Mendez on short notice
and won the the featherweight
championship of the world with a
knockout before that in Boston very
similar same Arena he uh dismantled
Dennis Siever with a TKO before that he
dismantled Dustin pore with a TKO
it's just it's those moments you know
it's those it's those moments that we
need I needed that out of
Gary that's it that's my only knock on
the guy if there's any criticism which
there's not much the guy's face wasn't
touched against you know magni
I do like it that we don't the other
thing we didn't find out much about Ian
Gary in that fight either we knew I I
know how good I think he is
he it wasn't even a fight dude against
Neo Magnum number 11 guy in the world
so even that I know I'm being hard on
but even that's like Neil magni is a
Savage he didn't that fight wasn't
competitive dude in any facet that's how
goody and Machado Gary is I'm telling
you you guys need to be all in on
imacado Gary now
his Antics outside it's it's just
I I can't put my finger I don't know
what it is it's rubbing people the wrong
way
but what do you because we say be
authentic from what I hear people around
Ireland who know him Machado Gary's like
he's always been like this
he's oh he's always been like pizza
Carol I love I love that guy he he's a
you know journalist out there in Dublin
he's on forever he goes since his first
fight been around the guy he's talking
about world champion it's just the way
he talked
so if that's his authentic truth if
that's him being Ian you got to do it
you can't change for anybody so if a Tim
keeps doing it I just him flipping off
and Neil and Neil's a good dude
now Neil hits his kids I don't know did
you hear what he actually said though
I did I did I'm with Ian on this here it
is that's this actual statement there's
a whooping that you give your son now to
kind of teach him a life a little bit
being a father become quite accustomed
to that kind of whooping now and that's
what I'm looking forward to giving on
Saturday I'm with Ian on this I don't
co-sign this just again just do some
research man there's extensive studies
saying hating your kids does nothing
it's 2023 man that information is
available you don't need to hit your kid
also could have just been sloppy trash
talk that's what I was thinking that's I
think he's doing that you think a sloppy
trash talk
he wanted to say he wants no Neil's the
nicest guy yeah I've known Neil for a
hot second before he's in the UFC Neil's
such a nice guy he's such a good person
so I don't think he's beating his kid in
any regard also Neil isn't the best
trash talker it's just not what he does
he's just not he's too nice he's just I
nicknamed the gazelle he was named
nicknamed the gazelle for about I don't
know 10 years and all of a sudden he's
the Nigerian Nightmare nobody's buying
that dude you're too nice to be the
nightmare so I think for Neil you might
be right could just be sloppy trash talk
he's also not a trash talker it's just
not what he does the Haitian Sensation
okay no you're the gazelle dude
near the gazelle because he's so nice
great endurance elusive
not scared of him but he'll he'll he'll
keep you busy that's him dude you know
but uh yeah it could be just sloppy
trash shot because that's not his that's
not his realm he's like beat you like I
beat my kid [__]
and then of course Ian Machado Gary
who's pretty Savvy at trash I was like
you do what he's like oh no
but even then you think Ian would
realize that but even after the fight he
ain't still not cool with a man yeah it
was like um it didn't seem real that
that's why it kind of rubbed me the
wrong way but for anybody who knows Ian
says that's where that's him the
multiple times even after he won
flipping him off I know it was still
alive and this is my only message but
this is where I'm confused
if that's Ian Machado Gary if that's him
you have to live your truth and keep
doing that dude and eventually you just
keep winning people are gonna either be
on board or up either way they're gonna
tune in to watch a win or lose that's
what we want when people don't care it's
a nightmare we can't use you as long as
people have some it's the Floyd
Mayweather it's the Conor McGregor as
even for Comics don't take us on the
road people are going to hate you people
love you but when you're in the middle
ain't nobody buying a ticket and getting
a babysitter watch the guy who plays it
safe never you got to be pretty extreme
so for Ian I guess keep doing your thing
my thing is if that is truth keep doing
your thing
if it's not
we don't need it dude your skills are so
goddamn good we don't need it Izzy
didn't have to do this stuff obviously
is he should talk now and do his stuff
you don't have to do this he we don't
need it
we don't need it the flipping off all
that stuff if it was a different
opponent and there was like some really
bad blood there but on two week notice
dude
we don't need that man like I don't need
it out of the UK but also Ian's young
was he 25 yeah these young kids that's
what they do
I'm just saying his skill set's so
[__] good
now he called out Wonder Boy a
four-year-old Wonder Boy I know he's a
striker so that ain't even one
everybody's like no hell no I'm fighting
this young buck yeah it's your goddamn
mind I'm thinking another older fella
over here so I don't think that's
happened for Ian but if Ian likes to you
know talk trash Wonder Boy ain't the one
to do it too he's beloved man another
super nice guy he's such a nice guy he's
just and I'm sure you would come up with
something but even when when Ian was
gonna fight homeboy
um who's he supposed to fight and took
his mug shot out oh Jeff Neal Jeff Neal
it's like that was messed up dog oh my
God these guys are savages I he just
doesn't need to do it but if you're his
manager you're going people are talking
about him people are tuning to watch him
fight he's selling merch
UFC likes it I just don't think we need
it I'm also 40. but he's he's so good to
watch so yeah he does oh my God he's
good now what's next for him one boy
ain't happening one boy's gonna fight
Camaro he's 40 be cool
um shot
damn
let that sink in
I mean that'd be amazing but that's like
two
Rising Stars
that's what we do baby that's what we do
I mean I want to see it but also shot
could get because in gear is a bigger
name shotgun yeah for sure the map but
bigger than amongst the masses
and the thing with this what you do with
Ian Gary
he's so good that the the number 11 guy
I know short knows I don't care Neo
Magnus cardio for days so that's not an
excuse
he out
Master Neil Matt I mean you're talking
it looked like an amateur that's Neil
magni he's ranked number 11. he's been
there with everybody he made him look
amateur so you can't
you just can't toss him Vicente lique
Sean Brady Neil he could go back to Neil
fight but I I'm one of those guys when
the fight falls out like that I'm good
nah I don't want to see it I already had
in my mind I was gonna go I'm good uh
Wonderboy Thompson's 40 can't do it so
so you can't really do like the the
guy's 12 you could do Kevin Holland I
might be into that I'm into that Kevin
Hall and fight that's got a match
already though I know fun bike but take
Kevin Hall at but 11 through seven when
you outclass the number 11 guy in the
world like that we got we gotta we gotta
go up we got to go up we gotta and he's
on the fast track he's that skilled too
we got to go up I think you do shopkat
damn
not a fight night
that's a co-main event on a pay-per-view
in December
and if sugar is fighting Cheeto that's
your co-main event because that's your
next star
John Scott's not your next I'm not
shopkat's not your next massive star
Inger is your next star now skill wise I
don't know shotgun's [__] good he's
full he's good he's so good
but if Ian Gary beats that we're going
Sizzler dude
Kevin Holland be a fun fight there's
also a guy number 14 he has a matchup
but uh Jack Della madelina yeah who's
fighting Kevin who's fighting Kevin Hall
so you could do the winner of JDM versus
Kevin Holland against Ian Gary but again
he beat the 11 guy he just didn't beat
him it's 30 24 30 10 for God's sakes you
gotta jump up in competition he's
surpassed those guys he said he was here
15 through 10. you Pat you pass that
test so well all right we gotta go we
gotta go up that's where he's at that's
how good this kid is I know UFC sees
that and you've seen and I think UFC
hopefully goes back to Dublin so if you
beat shopkot
then then you're talking about a top
five guy and you do that in Dublin main
card
Kevin the winner of Kevin Holland JDM
would be a fun one but I I
think Ian's a step ahead of those guys
as far as where where his career's
headed
could have shot's record for me Jen
who who would you guys have him
isn't that a great fight yeah it's
actually amazing but I think shop caught
right now
he beat
so he took out Neil you gotta finish
over Neil
both Nails both kneels
I think Ian beats him dude
[Music]
that's why it's a great fight because uh
I don't know but I would lean towards
shot
you would yeah lean we gotta bet if they
fight yeah take you in that fight
I think first second round tail
especially after seeing shaft versus
Neil Jeff Neal
the other obviously I was saying I
wanted to finish out of um
Ian Gary against the old magni Neo magni
was compromised and wasn't coming
forward in any faster just it's tough to
finish a guy when he's turtleing up like
that so that's it's very tough to finish
a guy who's not
playing the game oh it's very tough to
finish because he was just he's lagging
his hands are up like he's kind of
shelling on his feet it's no different
than the guy when he shells up on the
ground he's at one foot up and he's just
like this against Gage not engaging not
risking anything so it doesn't open up
counters or anything
so you know there's that too for you and
Gary
yeah all in on I mean Gary I just yeah
it's just the heat I need to do this
mean stuff yeah especially against the
good guys if you fight a nasty guy fire
away when you're fighting a guy like
Neil magni who [__] up and said he
beats his kid he was like oh no oh man
and the way that um uh Ian was going
after him like he was like it went
overboard like it's only it felt a
little little thick what do you mean
about the I would never you kids are
this now you know did you see do you see
his Vlog he's like oh oh oh did you see
that I'm like oh Neil [__] up but this
is it but again that's what these young
kids these 25 year they get anything
yeah it's oh my God it's this
overreaction and let's get him it's just
and that's the internet in general get
um
it's like oh man Neil you know
he's like no I don't beat my ah man I
just wanted to say he's known as well
yeah I'm gonna whip your ass like whip
my yeah it's gonna be that easy because
he's a kid
he's like you said what he's like no no
I don't mean like real ah damn yeah and
now that's it now Neil's known as a kid
beater
ain't that a [__]
yeah even child Gary real deal man
uh waylay versus Amanda limos I mean
just
it was a night full of I was texting you
guys during the fight it wasn't the best
card we've seen you know for a variety
of reasons because you had the decision
with Cheeto
but before that you had just this cringy
like one eye open Chris Weidman trying
to make sure his leg didn't fall off
against Brad Tavares because decision
like oh my God this is terrible I think
a decision with Cheeto and then the
Blackshear who I thought got robbed I
had Blackshear win that fight shout out
to Blackshear
that's another one we're like throwing
the towel that was one of those and then
you get
playing wayleigh just I mean just
beating the [__] out of mandolin I mean
just not even the same class dude so it
was almost like you had a bunch of weird
mismatches but they couldn't finish him
besides uh Cheeto and Pedro then you had
uh Batista and black shirt those were
good right the competitive fights even
though blackster got screwed over but
Chris Weidman out class right in that
fight it was tough to watch Neo magni
outclass on one leg a man in limos
outclass just just complete beatdowns
that wouldn't stop
this wouldn't it's like watching Isis
beheading it but it's 15 minutes long
you're like oh God just stop this
goddamn thing you know you can't fast
forward so it's just these massacres
just these mismatches the way they just
beat the shower now I'll tell you what
Waylon doing that to our girl Tatiana
schwarza tell you right now
talk about the the hype train stopper I
think swarza has something to say about
it the only issue for schwarza for
Tatiana there is gonna be the Striking
well it hits like a Mack truck she puts
some combinations together grappling
well ain't hearing a peep out of Tatiana
Tatiana bully that girl Tatiana beats
her whoa
hey Tatia beats the [__] out of her
chest beats the [__] out of her man
handles her throws her around oh that's
another bet then yep yep all right yeah
I'll bet that all day
I mean the only issue would be the
grapple I'm not worried in any faster I
think when it comes to the ground game
Tatiana is going to straight up khabib
her bully hurt you've never seen her get
manhandled like that you see what she's
done to some of these other contenders
who are known to be strong and she's
just playing Just toying with them she'd
do the same to waylay but the the
strikings where I get if you are Tatiana
fan that gets a little dicey or
striking's not great uh Waylon hits like
a Mack truck he puts combination
together the leg kicks could be an issue
but once you it goes to the ground which
it will
good night sweet friends
you know what I'm saying covina's finest
beat the [__] out of the thing lately oh
she's from Covina yep
wow another September 8th Brian Callan
me and Brian Callum back for the first
time oh yeah only Friday night Saturday
we're supposed to be in Austin
it's supposed to
oh what do you got chin
um you touched on this a little bit with
Chris Weidman uh you said he deserves at
least one more you know fight before he
retires favorable fight favor if I am
but Dana White is pleading basically at
the post by press conference pleading
with him to retire he says he loves him
and he says now he has like another what
some sort of Cl surgery or seal injury
oh ACL or ACL oh on the other leg though
yeah oh no I'm with Dana on this so it's
gonna be another year let's go ahead
just call it night I thought he was okay
just had some swelling but was but yeah
I hope that I heal my legs and get one
more in a favorable matchup and that's
it but if you have to have another knee
surgery he's gonna be out first shut
down chop here yeah I'm with Dana on
this but Chris wants to come back
um so this we're in the headlines I
don't know how how realistic this is but
uh Sean O'Malley did call out gervante
he wants to have a boxing Master Javonte
Davis and since you know the UFC was
able to do McGregor versus Floyd
Mayweather he says there's yeah that's
never happened no it's not it's never
happening again no the UFC's they're
never gonna and they have rules in place
and structures in place in the contracts
where the you're never gonna see Connor
another Conor again to have that much
power and be able to you know fight a
Floyd May Mayweather the UFC's never
gonna let that happen again nor do they
need to business-wise now they've
structured the business where they don't
want that to happen but uh speaking of
Javonte Davis and Suga a terrible fight
for sugar it's just it's silly but this
is the this is what happens this is the
product that UFC built this wouldn't
happen if sugar Sean was paid like
Javonte Davis this wouldn't happen if
Francis was paid like a Tyson Fury this
wouldn't happen if Nate Diaz was paid
like a Jake Paul
the reason why these guys get to the
highest level UFC and then they call out
boxers they're not going to beat any of
these guys name one UFC guys that's beat
a boxer
I'll wait
just inside the UFC James Tony that's it
he got his ass I don't name one UFC guy
that's beat a boxer in boxing outside
the UFC it's never gonna happen
it's just not
it's not what we it's a different
language
they might as well compete in swimming
it's just the the I know both Combat
Sports doesn't matter you're talking
about apples and oranges it's never
gonna happen you should be more mad at
the reason that the UFC fighters aren't
compensated like the big name boxers
no the argument there is in general from
number one to 500 UFC fighters are paid
significantly more than boxers the one
percent the oh one percent of boxing is
competed tremendously but those are the
guys that you know so you go well these
guys make all the money but UFC doesn't
it's a different business model
the on those undercards of the boxing
those guys are making like 500 bucks
world champions are making like two
grand
no but they don't have a phone so no one
speaks up for them
the tank Davis is the world Deontay
Wilders the Tyson Furious Anthony
Joshua's the Charlo Brothers the the
canelos of the world you can name about
the Terence Bud crawfords the Earl
Spence you can name probably if if
you're into boxing 15 guys who make real
that that outlier money
in the UFC I can name a hundred guys who
make a damn good living
it's just a different model but they're
not making the type of money that a
Javonte Davis is making that of Tyson
Fury is making so that's why they're
calling these guys out it's a product of
the pay scale it's a shame they have
they feel they have to do this to get
compensated
because don't get wrong Sugar's making a
[__] ton of money but he's not making
Canelo money but remember Canelo Canelo
would be it would basically it'd be like
if
it'd be like if Dana was a current an
active world champion fighter and owned
the the UFC and just took all the money
that's basically what Canelo is he's the
promoter he's the owner and he's the
best in the world so of course he gets
the Lion's Share and then they don't
have to pay the undercard
so because of their pay scale because
this is the business they went in the
direction they went in now everyone gets
to the top they're calling out the
boxers
everyone wants to be Connor because he
changed it forever
but not only did Conor change it forever
he changes so much you see he's never
gonna let allow that to happen again
it's never happened again they gave
Connor too much power
he had too much of the line sharing the
Earth he went oh we messed up good and
bad they sold the cover for two billion
but they're never gonna allow that to
happen four four billion they're never
allowed to happen again
so I see this stuff I'm like apartment's
like oh God damn it sugar but also
that's that's what these guys do they
get to the very top and they call these
guys out
you're never going to see it nor does
UFC can entertain it
it's because it's not good when Connor
did that he was kind of he already had
his run it's already we already had our
good time with him when he did that I
was like okay we'll entertain this never
been done before sugar is sugar 28 yeah
28. you think the UFC is gonna say hey
this is one of the most best strikers in
our world
and you you think they want him to get
embarrassed by Tank Davis he would get
embarrassed I love sugar and now tank
would get embarrassed in the UFC as much
as sugar would embarrass tank in the UFC
tank would embarrass him in boxing
it's not knock on sugar slime not
contained you're talking about two
different things they might as well play
basketball
it'd be more competitive if they play
basketball I think sugar beats the [__]
out of them is so tall yeah it's so tall
and I think he actually plays yeah but
the comparison's silly
doc would never allow that to happen
same way they didn't want Francis
fighting Tyson
you want the the guy who's the face the
best knockouters well time to get
dismantled in a minute
now can Francis land something yes
because Sugar Land some yes the chance
that happened are not good it's all
these guys do
boxers have a better chance of winning
in the UFC than UFC fighters do in
boxing
because boxers can land that special
punch with MMA gloves on MMA fighters
get hit boxers at the highest level you
don't see them get hit a lot do you
they're pretty [__] good at it
boxers have a chance to land in in MMA
MMA really their chance of Landing is
not good in boxing it's all those guys
do and all they have to worry about is
your hands they've seen it all they've
seen every big right hand big left hook
uppercut speed Jabs South Paul different
angles awkward guys they have hundreds
and hundreds of matches before they even
get to the highest level and mma's not
like that it's just not
so yeah I see that stuff I'm like What's
the world we live in
I guess it'll never happen now can sugar
well I I'm not gonna say it never
happens but it's never gonna happen in
the UFC now five years from now after
sugar has this long rain six years from
now he's whatever 10 title defenses he's
the face of it he's getting a little
weathered his last finalist contract and
he's like hey I want to fight Javonte
and you'll see he goes no he's right I'm
out that's what Nate Diaz does goes out
and he fights tank do you want to watch
it then I don't know both of me older
all right
um but that's the world we live in
yeah
so uh Jake Paul did a podcast recently
and then he said that the pay-per-view
buys for him versus Nate was around 500
000 which is good and then it also broke
first of all that's tremendous
it's phenomenal yeah go ahead but I mean
once again we don't know the facts facts
you know right
but uh also so it has
yeah I think he said it was the actual
gate record but it's like second place
behind the UFC gate record so according
to Paul the vet was a huge success for a
financial perspective
um it's looking like 500k plus Bay
reviews biggest gate in the US and
that's USA U.S pay-per-views so it means
more because it costs more in the US so
massive numbers massive success there's
statistics that show the Google search
from that night we were number one most
searched Google Trend by 10 times
trending everywhere biggest gate biggest
ticket sales biggest sponsorship biggest
sponsorship I believe uh biggest gate
yeah that's tough uh because Canelo also
fought in the Dallas Arena
so this is what I saw for the records
there
second highest recorded gate for a
Combat Sports event at that at that
particular venue and it
only surpassed by UFC 277 which is weird
because that's Nunez versus uh
gosh dang it
Nunez versus Pena too
that's not a big one yeah
but that's from the Dallas news it's
still pretty even even if no I'm already
surprised even seconds insane
so at 59.99 Pay-Per-View price point in
the US that this means the event
generated just under 30 million without
even considering ticket sales and
sponsorship
those boys got paid huge success
if I'm Jake you know who I fight next
ready for this
Robbie Lawler
forget the boxing World dude keep
beating up MMA guys with these huge fan
bases making all the money keep taking
out these great Strikers in the UFC who
cares about getting validated from
boxing they're never going to accept you
ever if you beat Canelo Becca canoe
that's never happening
keep making your money bro and getting
these huge fights against these ex-ufc
guys who have huge fan bases because the
MMA Community is buying this stuff we're
a pay-per-view model we we like buying
paypalies we support our guys everyone
loves Robbie Lawler everyone loves Nate
Diaz people love Woodley keep doing that
if people love Anderson Silva keep doing
that get your money
keep beating up these non-boxers these
great Strikers
keep doing that I don't get who gives a
[__] about the internet
keeping out the dope videos you beat up
Robbie Robbie Lawler do that for a huge
payday 15 mil for Robbie Lawler damn
I don't know how well that would do
though what do you think it's Jake
you could build that easily Robbie
Lawler UFC Hall of Famer former world
champion a bunch of highlights but you
can't really show them then I don't know
yeah I don't know how it would do though
former world champion Nate Diaz wasn't a
champion rugby law is a champion Doug he
was
now he's obviously don't have the fame
as Nate
it's a good story there keep doing that
and that'd be great for Robbie and
that's why we should support it don't I
don't care what how you feel about Jake
Paul
name another organization another fight
Robbie could take where he's going to
make let's see say he only makes 5
million which is low for a Jake Paul
fight let's say made five million name
another organization another fight
Robbie Lawler or in insert whatever MMA
Legend name you want where they can get
paid that amount of money for boxing
Jake Paul
there's no other place on planet that's
why you should celebrate what Jake's
doing keep that same energy I've told
you guys this keep that statement you
want to hate on Dana hey in the UFC for
not paying their guys their worth Jake's
paying him their worth but you guys hate
on it
which one do you like here
name another fight Nate Diaz could take
where he'll make 15 million or 20
million dollars
Conor McGregor nope he ain't making that
much
it's also easier fight for him even if
they lose it's an easier fight a boxing
Camp is way easier than getting ready
for an MMA fight in the UFC it just is
you only have to worry about hands you
don't have to Grapple you don't have to
[__] worry about kicks elbows the
ground game there's none of that stuff
just boxing it's also easier on these
older guys
so you should be celebrating whoever
Jake picks you should be telling Jake
hey fight Robbie fight this guy the next
older UFC Hall of Famer we want this for
these guys because they're getting that
this is their 401K this is their
Redemption to getting screwed over by
the UFC for all those years on the pay
nobody else is offering that money you
guys should be celebrating that Jake's
Creed this path for your favorite UFC
fighter nobody else is doing it guys
despite how you feel about Jake I don't
care about your feelings about him but
he's doing nobody else is doing for your
favorite Fighters
what do you got Jen
all right so this is a quick story about
Colby Covington saying that uh Jon Jones
he went to the people behind the scenes
UFC brass to not have Colby Covington on
the same card as him because he's
fearful of all the stuff like especially
during the press conference and all that
stuff all the you know the because he's
been with them since like what college
days yeah their roommates there's a lot
of dirt on him he's like afraid that
he's gonna it's gonna come out so he
said that this is what is a legit thing
and I think John addick even said like
he he takes Colby at his word for it
yeah it's tough right because Colby says
a lot of things throws a lot of mud at
the wall yeah but maybe there's
something there
I guess I thought that was interesting
and apparently it worked he's not gonna
find on the same card
that's a bummer I know against us Leon
would be great Main Event oh we talked
about this one already but so this is
going to be Jack delamount madelaina
versus Kevin Holland at nochioc which is
like the Mexican Independence Day
who's the main event do we know the main
who is Alexa Grosso chefchenko I believe
that's a great fight yeah I see a winner
of that getting homeboy
Daniel Rodriguez a great fight
a girl Tracy Cortez is fighting
Cynthia calvillo yep that's a fun one
all right all right and here's another
announcement this one's interested to me
when I saw that my goof Mackenzie Dern
versus Jessica andrej UFC 295.
she looks really good here always looks
good I know
going for going for her Jessica and Josh
she's found some tough she is yeah she's
she's lost it the only tip of the spare
people
I'm surprised she's jumping right back
in there
hopefully McKenzie can get done
uh this one also is interesting Chase
Hooper versus the sugar tank dude Jordan
11 Sweet Love yeah
I like that guy I like Jordan I follow
him he's he's entertaining yeah he's a
good dude seems like but they're both
good people
um yeah I root for Jordan yeah it has a
fun matchup yeah
um that's let's see here oh so this
one's just a for some reason James
Krause he was still on the UFC roster
for this long time and I guess he just
barely got removed and then
there were you know people are wondering
why it took a year for him to be removed
but yeah he is being investigated by the
FBI and then yeah so who knows what's
gonna happen with him but he's not
removed from the roster it's weird they
wait so long yeah
um
oh well let's touch on this real quick
Jake Paul says that UFC should increase
their minimum wage for UFC fighters to
50K that'd be dope I mean and it's
doable right of course it is yeah but
why would you do it I know UFC
also the the other parlay to that is I
mean I think it has to be it'd be great
if they did get paid more but also doc
has the issue of when guys get fat and
happy similar to baseball players those
baseball players may get paid aren't
very good anymore with UFC there's a few
outliers but you look at Conor
McGregor's a certain although is these
different John's different but like
Conor McGregor has all the money in the
world it's tough man for Fighters when
they come from nothing they have all
this money they just don't have the same
grit you know
so Dave likes to keep him hungry
I know
so but it makes sense though obviously
if you have if you're 300 mil
they don't run his stuff yeah
baseball's the worst baseball you know
I've gotten really in baseball league
but you'll see you guys get paid and
it's just don't get around there's a few
outliers but once they get because and
it's awesome baseball it's guaranteed
so they get this whatever 300 million
guaranteed like what happened they're
like I don't want to play anymore man
I'm loaded dude
that's why I like Izzy Ebina as active
as he is and having that money
insane yeah so dope real martial arts
because you won't see guys as active
either you'll see guys still doing the
work but not like they did when they're
coming up you'll see them they fight
once a year maybe once every 18 months
once they get paid is he active dude
does It For the Love of the Game and
goes after the people that just going
after whoever whoever he's like that guy
next that guy next UFC didn't want uh
Strickland give me him can't you I beat
him
because word is the UFC didn't want
strictly let me get title shot because
obviously he's a liability on the mic
the guy speaks his truth yeah you know
so the UFC was like if this guy becomes
Jam we're losing all sponsorship I'm
pretty sure word on the street is is he
called Daniel's like I guarantee you I
beat this guy you don't have to worry
about him
that's how the fight got happened that's
why it took so long to get done too
people saying V's on us he didn't want
to happen is he went hey real quick
guarantee that piece this guy up just do
it
you see one okay he wins though we're
screwed that'd be trippy that'd be such
a trip did we discuss the Conor voice
thing already author or honor no okay
yeah I talked a little bit with case
before this
yeah so yeah go ahead oh so Connor's
saying he did this voice thing again
which is very awkward and then he's
saying that they're not gonna let me
fight in December
um they're taking away my livelihood or
something livelihood I was like dude you
have 300 million dollars in the bank I
know it was funny
um but yeah it's deleted but here says
they're not they're they're not gonna
let me fight they're not meaning you saw
it in UFC yeah in December's ladies and
gentlemen uh you've seen what happened
to Chris Weidman imagine what that
injury is and to be kept I feel like
I've been kept from my livelihood I'm
not gonna air grievances I'm not gonna
I'm gonna bite Down Soldier on I'm ready
I'm ready yeah I wanted to announce
December 16th I've given everything so
you know it's not going to happen
doesn't look like it's going to happen
but anyway I hold the power we're just
gonna keep doing our thing like I said
I'm in a great spot I'll see you soon
hopefully early next year please God
come on Ari Emmanuel I'm ready yeah
December 16th I'm ready if anyone wants
to go
um
yeah
it's just it's just it's tough being
such a Connor fan you see this you know
the thing I didn't like and I if anyone
notice
so Ian Machado Gary his hair is Conor
McGregor
and there's very there's a lot of
similarities there Connor's always he's
always gave props to Ian when he's
fought and built him up and obviously if
Connor koson just a big deal and he gets
more followers more traction kind of say
anything about him
and I think it's because you know Ian
signed with that better which is Jake
Paul's betting site you signed with
better and I think you know Connor views
that as competition or whatever doesn't
like him so he just didn't give any
shine to emojado Gary which say come on
dude business is business I can
understand if Conor had his own betting
site and Gary turned that down and went
with Jake then yeah you're like dude
what are you talking about we're [__]
Irish Brothers and you go with the Enemy
but if you don't have your own gamma
like let's say you took on
let's say Nate Diaz had his own whiskey
it's called whatever is real as it is
whiskey and he signed with him over
proper then I get not say anything but
you know the business dude it's money
yeah Ian's a young kid with a family he
has to get his where he can get it where
he fit in you know so that I that kind
of steered me the wrong way also
whenever you know this was suga's night
this was serious night and Connor Yuji
tries to step on like nope don't forget
about me you know he kind of did that
here but not to the fullest extent but
um you know it was it was suga's night
sugar is kind of the he's the new breed
the new wave is here you know and he's
pretty [__] talented and he's pretty
goddamn good on the mic too you know so
I don't know it the Connor stuff buns me
out
yep
I know you love everything Conor does
dude I I defend him too I love Connor
but it just
it's tough I just wonder what's going on
I don't know I don't know what's going
on there yeah uh well check this out um
JDS is looking even more jacked right
now
and you see his abs through his shirt
right here
God I wish I had the same acai he was on
right now
dude him versus verdum is gonna be
something nuts house yeah because it's
gamebread's bare knuckle it's not bare
knuckle boxing y'all it's bear knuckle
MMA against verdum who's also on the
same acai
take my money dude this thing is nuts on
September 8th too yeah
he is yeah yeah dude good for them
yeah otherwise we've probably done a
companion for it
well maybe right
well that is pretty much it dude those
were good you have a UFC fight night
going down in Singapore this Saturday
it's at 5 00 a.m Pacific time so but the
main card starts at 5am
I mean that's what it says here so I'm
just gonna record it well I wake up at
six that's not the end of the deal it's
not the end of the world
yeah I'm up at 5 36 so [__] I'll be
watching it yeah I was gonna say I'm not
waking up it'll probably start at like
seven anyway
the main card starts at 5am 5 a.m but
then the main event probably will seven
or eight we could baby I'll watch that
thing live eat my Cheerios my kiddos and
my undies Anthony Smith Ryan Spahn
that's a rematch there giga's fighting
out curious that's a good fight
here in blanchfield that's a big one
Santos that's a big one the flyweight
division
you had heavyweights you just gotta hope
those early cards don't the early fights
don't go fast because then you know I'll
be up though it's all good baby I'll be
up for this
yeah
it's a fun card you made a vet you got
Max Holloway versus Korean zombie
you know
speaking of sacrifices speaking of beat
downs you can never oh my God that's
probably some minus 850.
Plus 520.
this is one of those fights where I'm
like I'll take Max holiday and Korean
zombie somehow like Clips I'm like oh
you got that one wrong job you're always
wrong I went four for six you idiot
zombie though no sure did it I think Max
always gonna pepper his Korean face into
North Korea that's what I think his face
can go from south to North that's why I
think it's gonna happen gotta believe
this fight's so
messed up I
mean Korean zombie asks for he's been
yeah he's been One Max and Max wanted
Korean so or green zombie Team Max all
day I'm team Anthony Smith all day
yeah I mean I'll tune in I'll watch it
yeah
I'll watch the sacrifice in the morning
of Saturday Saturday I'll watch that to
that or morning cartoons with the kiddos
yeah should be a fun fight sorry kiddos
no cartoons today we're gonna watch
Korean zombie get annihilated
enjoy your Cheerios and blood this
morning oh man
yeah it is what it is it is that it
that's it that's a fun one man UFC's
popping right now uh Covina September
8th that's at the Laugh Factory in
Covina great new club up there but it's
me and Brian counting together for the
first time in a hot second it's being
Brian Cohen Covina two shows I think
seven and nine thirty or something like
that but two shows only on uh Friday
September 8th in Covina because
September 9th we're doing a fight
campaign with Mr Joe Rogan and then
September 21st through the 23rd one of
my favorite clubs Spokane Washington
love spoken and then I'll be at skank
Fest in Vegas to end September 29th
through October 1st uh we have a bunch
of dates being announced probably this
week but we have Niagara Falls November
4th through the 5th those tickets go on
sale Friday for Niagara Falls Casino out
there
I guess I go check out Niagara Falls
that's what you do there right so it's a
casino out in Niagara Falls New York but
I will be out there but we have
refresh my memory we have Iowa coming up
Damon Des Moines Iowa in October and
then in December we have Chicago I've
been to Chicago in a hot second so
um I'll be my Cubs Jersey out there in
Chicago I'll be my Iowa Hawkeyes uh gear
in Iowa in October but Covina you're up
first then Spokane skank Fest Vegas
Niagara Falls Iowa Chicago that's to
close out the year that's it kids oh
update on my son I post by my social
media made the team baby oh hell yeah
operations commitment summer baseball
went down I try not to put any pressure
on them didn't want to realize how how
much anxiety I had but uh he got it done
man so shout out to the little dude
we'll look back on this and realize I
was really stressed out about it but
yeah he did it man awesome
all right guys love ya see you around
the way Thursday I'm at the Laugh
Factory I'll be doing spots all around
town all right love you guys till next
time I'm out